Some of these stories are so unbelievable,
unbelievable that they actually do seem like
they're not real, except they are.
And I've
talked about the problem with calling them
unbelievable because it actually creates a
sort of disbelief of things that are all too
real and should horrify us.
And this is going to be sort of a short story
since it's still developing.
I did want to briefly cover it.
A top Trump national security advisor has
been reportedly escorted out of the white
house and placed on leave when it was uncovered
that they were potentially a security risk.
Remember we were told Donald Trump can be
trusted to hire the right people, that you
can be trusted with sensitive information,
with information security, all of that stuff.
Hillary couldn't be trusted except then Trump
is spilling secrets to Russian spy recruiters
in the oval office using unsecured, uh, devices
that he refuses to have screened.
And here appears to have someone who's a security
risk working in the white house.
I'm talking about a guy named Andrew peek.
Andrew peek is or was the senior director
for European and Russian affairs at the national
security council.
This is like one of Trump's top Russia advisors.
He is now on leave and a security investigation
is taking place.
Trump had someone on the national security
council previously at the state department,
his top person on Russia involved in all sorts
of sensitive areas and that guy had to be
escorted out of the white house by security.
The white house was asked for comment.
They said, we don't discuss security matters,
which of course confirms that this is a security
matter.
A peek himself was asked to comment, said,
no comment.
So it's not just that Donald Trump is hiring
bad people, he's hiring people who are potentially
security threats that security has to escort
out.
But the bigger picture issue is that this
is the third time in a year that this position
is vacant.
Nevermind other positions of importance, and
someone sent me a funny message because peak
advises Trump on Russia stuff.
I got an email that said, Hey David, do you
think peak was escorted out because it was
revealed he's in cahoots with Putin or do
you think he was escorted out because it was
revealed that he's not in cahoots with Putin
and that doesn't work for Donald Trump?
Very clever at this point.
It's all speculation.
I actually think that the entire security
threat story might be false.
And I'll explain what I mean by that.
Andrew peek was an intelligence officer for
a long time.
He has a doctorate in international affairs.
He was appointed, I believe, by David Petraeus
under the Barack Obama administration.
It's possible that Trump missed this guy in
the firings of Obama people.
And now after the Iranian fat fiasco, it's
possible.
Peek started speaking out saying what you're
doing is crazy.
And then it was realized by the Trump administration.
Oh damn, how did this guy slip through the
cracks?
He's got to go, let's escort him out and say
that there's a security investigation going
on.
I, it's mere speculation.
It's all crazy.
I don't know what the final resolution would
be, but remember it was Trump who said, I
will hire the best people.
It was Trump who said, the people around me
are just going to be the best.
And, uh, you know, that if you want proof
that Trumpists were bamboozled by that line,
think back to someone else who tried to use
that same bullet point and was excoriated
Herman Cain, Herman Cain is this pizza entrepreneur
who ran for president, uh, for the Republican
nomination.
I want to say it was 2012 although maybe it
was in 2008.
And can you imagine if that was 12 years ago?
It feels so recent.
Anyway, Herman Cain ran for the Republican
nomination and one of the things that Herman
Cain started saying early on when he was asked
about what would your policy be in Afghanistan,
or you know, people were asking policy, uh,
heavy questions.
He would say, haven't figured it out yet,
but I'm going to put the best person in charge
of figuring that out.
And maybe his followers sort of bought it,
but the Republican party at large did not
buy it and he was completely laughed at and
his campaign fell apart relative relatively
quick, quickly after he said that.
On the other hand, you've had Donald Trump
effectively saying the same thing, which is
that Donald Trump did a better job of pretending
to know about stuff like trade and healthcare
or whatever.
But he also pushed a lot of the same idea
that he was going to hire the best people.
He was going to drain the swamp and put the
best people in.
It's really the same failed idea that Herman
Cain put forward about.
I'll figure it out when I get there and I'll
put people in place who are going to know,
but with Donald Trump at work than it actually
succeeded at bamboozling enough of his followers
and even enough Republicans who said, I trust
that Donald Trump is going to take our advice.
And Trump sometimes alluded to that by saying,
Hey, you know what?
Uh, I will select justices to the Supreme
court from a list given to me by, I think
it was the heritage foundation.
I will select judges for lower court levels
from lists that are generated by this group
or that group.
So Trump was equally clueless about a lot
of these policy issues, but he played the
game about hiring the right people.
Of course, it was a complete and total farce
and he didn't do that in a whole bunch of
his people have been indicted, if not forced
out for different reasons, many of them internationally
embarrassing.